[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est Camille chalmer s'il est économiste
et il est représentant de la plateforme
haïtienne de plaidoyer pour un
développement alternatif et il est avec
nous depuis Port-au-Prince en Haïti
merci d'être avec nous monsieur Chalmers
merci de l'invitation bonjour François
24 alors Chris politique Chris sécurité
et désormais crise sanitaire avec le
retour du choléra face à ces multiples
crises le secrétaire général des Nations
unies Antonio Gutierrez appelle ce
dimanche à l'envoi d'une force
internationale en Haïti ce qui fait
suite à une demande du Premier ministre
Ariel Henry votre réaction à la
possibilité d'envoi d'une force
internationale en Haïti
notre réaction c'est d'abord un
sentiment d'indiation sur le fait que il
y a une incompréhension totale
et une instrumentalisation de la crise
haïtienne puisque nous avons vécu
récemment depuis 1993 10 missions
successives des Nations Unies et toutes
ces missions en dépit des moyens très
importants qui ont été mis à leur
disposition ont échoué et non seulement
échoué mais en plus on t'aggravé la
nature de la crise sociétale en Haïti
ont contribué à affaiblir les
institutions éthiques on renforcer la
dépendance du pays par voie à
l'extérieur et on a plongé le pays dans
une situation catastrophique aujourd'hui
donc s'il est évident que ce n'est pas
la solution la solution ne peut pas
passer par la répétition des mêmes
erreurs et nous sommes indignés aussi
par le propos du secrétaire général des
nerfs Unis qui assimilé les
manifestations populaires de ces
dernières semaines
à des actions de banditisme alors qu'en
fait en Haïti nous vivons depuis 2016 un
cycle important de mobilisation
populaire qui dénonce justement les
politiques gouvernementales et qui
dénoncent les politiques néolibérales et
qui dénoncent les tentatives d'effacer
les gants les gains démocratiques qui
ont été arrachés par les lutte du peuple
haïtien depuis la chute de la dictature
donc nous avons affaire à un mouvement
de fond un soulèvement citoyen qui
réclame justice qui réclame la
démocratie et qui protestent contre des
politiques anti-nationales antipopulaire
et qui aggrave la crise structurelle de
la société haïtienne alors est-ce que
vous pensez comme je l'ai dit cette
appel du Secrétaire général de l'ONU
fait suite à un appel du Premier
ministre Ariel Henry est-ce que dans
votre esprit c'est une façon pour Ariel
Henry de ce légitimer et d'obtenir
j'allais dire le cachet de la communauté
internationale parce qu'on sait qu'il
est arrivé dans des conditions très
chaotiques et qui reste contesté
aujourd'hui en Haïti
tout à fait nous avons affaire un
Premier ministre qui n'a aucune source
de légitimité qui n'a aucune source
légale et qui n'a présenté jusqu'à
présent aucun calendrier
électoral au club processus de sortie de
cette situation transitoire donc nous
sommes en présence de situation tout à
fait hors constitution inacceptable et
c'est justement ce genre de situation
que le peuple haïtien a toujours rejeté
depuis les grands mouvements populaires
de 86 nous ne voulons pas être dirigés
par un système autocratique où toute la
décision sont prises par une
personnalité j'espère que aujourd'hui
est à la fois Premier Ministre Président
de la République et qui ne répond à
aucune question puisque il n'y a pas
d'institution comme par exemple le
Parlement
les institutions judiciaires qui
pourraient questionner ces politiques
donc justement on nous a imposé pendant
la caisse dernier mois un système
politique qui est un retour à
l'autocratie et un retour justement vers
tout ce que le pays a rejet et qui
constitue un frais à la Constitution à
la construction démocratique en Haïti et
un frein pour l'émergence de plan de
sortie de crise qui permettrait
justement de résoudre les problèmes de
fond de la société haïtienne alors le
secrétaire général de l'ONU des noms
aussi ce qu'il appelle les bandes
criminelles qui ont pris le contrôle
d'infrastructure stratégique le port de
Port-au-Prince le principal terminal de
carburant du pays à vareux est-ce que
pour vous ce sont de véritables gangs
criminels ou est-ce que c'est un petit
peu autre chose
nous avons affaire effectivement
beaucoup de gangs
criminels et c'est quelque chose qui
s'est renforcé au cours de cette
dernière mois et il faut voir que les
gangs criminels font partie de mécanisme
de domination récurrent en Haïti ou
justement pour faire face à la montée
des mouvements populaires et à la
demande de participation politique des
secteurs populaires
l'impérialisme et l'oligarchie local
utilisent deux formes de violence il y a
la violence à travers les forces
publiques institutionnalisées et il y a
la violence informelle à travers des
bandes armées qui se sont appelés
totalement il y a eu des Inglés d'eau il
y a eu des Attachés il y a eu le frappe
par exemple dans le coup d'État contre
Aristide en 1991 et c'est bon de
paramilitaires sont financés sont
entretenus par des forces économiques et
politiques en Haïti et dans le cas de la
conjoncture actuelle il est clair qu'il
y a une articulation politique mais
presque organique entre le pouvoir
central et ses bandes et ses bandes
armées nous avons vu par exemple quand
dans la conjoncture de Novembre Décembre
2021 quand le gouvernement a voulu
monter le prix des carburants on a
utilisé les gangs pour justement créer
une raretité artificielle de carburant
et passer à une augmentation
significative donc nous avons ici cela
le problème c'est que vous avez des
gants qui reçoivent des armes des
munitions sans limites et qui jouissent
d'une impunité presque totale donc la
solution à ce problème c'est justement
de couper ce lien organique entre le
pouvoir central et les gangs
paramilitaires et ceci répond à un
projet de l'extrême droite parce que
nous avons affaire à une extrême droite
qui est représentée surtout par le phtk
et d'autres alliés et qui veut justement
redéfinir le système politique haïtien
et et qui affirme sans cesse une espèce
de nostalgie par rapport à la période de
l'aide du valium mais là quand même vous
dites des choses très graves c'est à
dire que vous dites que le pouvoir donc
sa figure de proue en ce moment c'est le
premier ministre Ariel Henry utilise
sciemment ses gang qu'il dit combattre
par ailleurs à des fins politiques c'est
extrêmement grave quand même ce que vous
dites
oui oui c'est grave et c'est c'est vrai
et en fait au cours des dernières années
on a eu une quantité de fait une
quantité de documents quand c'est de
preuve qui montre les relations étroites
qui existent entre le PHP et les bandes
paramilitaires le Sénat de la République
a sorti des rapports là-dessus on a vu
par exemple quantité d'appels
téléphoniques entre un des sénateurs
représentant le PHP au Sénat et un chef
de bande de la antibonite donc il y a
des preuves accablante et la conjoncture
actuelle semble montrer justement qu'il
y a une instrumentalisation de cette
violence criminelle à des faits
politiques pour pour
conforter le pouvoir du phtk et
justifier aussi une intervention
militaire qui dans dans les différentes
cas que nous avons vécu ces dernières
années a toujours fait alliance aux
forces les plus rétrogrades et les plus
anti démocratiques de la nation donc si
je suis votre raisonnement les Nations
Unies donc j'imagine les États-Unis la
France le Canada des pays qui se sont
toujours occupés d'Haïti le font
sciemment ou peut-être parce qu'ils ne
se rendent pas compte le jeu des gangs
en soutenant visiblement le pouvoir en
place
tout à fait tout à fait et c'est ça
justement qui justifie l'indignation
collective du peuple haïtien c'est que
malgré le fait que par exemple journal
Moïse c'était montrer quelqu'un qui
méprisait complètement les institutions
démocratiques qui a détruit le Parlement
qui a essayé de détruire le pouvoir
judiciaire qui a essayé
d'instrumentaliser la Cour des comptes
Joël Moïse a toujours bénéficié d'un
appui inconditionnel de l'impérialisme
des États-Unis du Canada et de beaucoup
de force au niveau international et
c'est justement là le problème c'est que
nous avons à faire à une alliance entre
ces forces rétrogrades et ce qu'on
appelle la communauté internationale qui
a une lecture totalement
erronée de la crise haïtienne et de ce
qu'il faut faire pour aider le peuple
haïtien à résoudre cette crise qui a tué
jovenel Moïse
et jusqu'à présent il y a aucun élément
qui permet d'affirmer avec certitude qui
commodité ce crime ce qui est certain
c'est que nous avons une implication des
secteurs mafieux une implication des
circuits liés à la drogue et une
application aussi de des mercenaires
colombiens qui sont liés en général au
circuit des agents secrets américains
donc ce qui est certain c'est que cette
crime qui a été
accompagnée par de nombreuses
complicités et qui sont liées justement
à au lutte politique interne du phtk
dernière question que Michel maire s'est
étant donné le panorama qu'on vient de
dresser à ceci se rajoute dernièrement
le retour du choléra est-ce que vous
craignez une véritable explosion de
violence en Haïti et des troubles
vraiment sérieux
oui nous sommes effectivement dans une
conjoncture très très compliquée très
complexe et où le peuple haïtien est en
train de asphyxié
nous avons perdu tous les droits
fondamentaux et aujourd'hui on a presque
plus le droit de se déplacer à
l'intérieur de Port-au-Prince et je
pense que et effectivement cette
situation génère des conflits multiples
des affrontements multiples et
évidemment il faut dénoncer il faut des
décanter ce qui est l'action des gang et
par un militaire et l'Action
démocratique citoyenne de la
mobilisation populaire qui réclame
justement un changement de système qui
réclame une transition de rupture qui
permettrait de faire la lumière sur le
crime qui ont été commis sur lesquelles
financiers et de définir un système
politique qui soit à la hauteur des
aspirations du peuple haïtien donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes en présence d'un
gouvernement qui n'a plus le contrôle de
du territoire un gouvernement qui
justement s'est allié aux forces
mafieuse contre la population et
aujourd'hui on réclame la démission de
ce premier ministre et la mise en place
d'un régime de transition de rupture qui
permettrait justement de réorganiser
l'appareil les appareils de l'État et de
donner un autre sens à l'action publique
qui aujourd'hui est totalement
tergiverser dans le sens des intérêts
contraires et à la nation haïtienne que
Michel maire merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu aux questions de France 24
depuis Port-au-Prince en Haïti et merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien sur
nos antennes
chaque semaine entrez dans les coulisses
des batailles économiques au cœur de la
guerre économique Ali Heidi décrypte
avec son invité les stratégies
commerciales des entreprises et des
états là où tous les coups sont permis
l'entretien de l'intelligence économique
présenté par Ali Laïdi avoir sur France
24 et sur France 24 com